hello everyone this game comes as a
suggestion from a subscriber and it's
nothing short of a brilliant positional
masterpiece by carpet here Karpov takes
his opponent to the German Grand Master
of all penguins Iike I into an almost
perfect 2-1 the game was played in 1974
I was the Chess Olympiad in Nice France
and it's it's really an amazing game it
was one year before Karpov became world
champion but still facing Karpov in
those days with the black pieces was the
equivalent of a nightmare
so Karpov in this game has the white
pieces and he opens up with E for and
one more interesting thing about this
game it's the exact same game that was
played in 1907 between Ossie Bernstein
and Akiba Rubinstein until move 13 and
then Karpov and move 14 improves on this
game and takes it to in a whole new
direction but we'll get to that so II 5
we have Knight to f3 knight c6 and
Bishop to b5 dura Lopez a6 we have the
Murphy's defense Bishop to a4 Knight to
f6 white castles we have Bishop to e7
rook to e1 b5 Bishop to b3 b6 C 3 and
here Hunziker castles h3 Knight to a5
Bishop to C 2 this is still all standard
Theory c5 d for Queen to c7 Knight B to
d2 Knight to c6 and we have this d5 move
here and here black has a couple of
options he can retreat for example with
Knight to a5 he can go all night b8
night to a7 that's a bit more rare and
we have this Knight to d8 move and it
was night to d8 that was played in the
game between bursty Bernstein and
Rubinstein so night to d8 also by
Onizuka and here in the game between
Ossie Bernstein and Akiba Rubinstein
Knight the f1 was played the game
continuing with Knight to d7 and here
was the moment where Aussie Bernstein
pushed a 4 but it's a bit different than
in this game that Karpov is playing
after night the d8 Karpov doesn't go for
night to have one rather he pushes a 4
immediately and now there's no
for a move like Knight to d7 as a
capture some b5 will win a pawn since
black can't recaptured rook will capture
rook so after a four rook to b8 we have
a capture some b5 a capture some b5 and
here Karpov plays b4 so what do you do
here Knights the b7 is played now if if
you capture with C capture son before
after seek after some before let's say
Knight to d7 Knight to b3
this Knight is now coming to a 5 you
have to stop this for example night to
b7 but now white simply plays Bishop to
d3 Bishop to e3 he will put the Queen
and e2 for example in rook eat the c1
and it will be an excellent position for
white so instead after b4 night beat
night - b7 was played we have night - f1
by carp of Bishop to d7 Bishop to e3
rook to e8 Queen to d2 now so Karpov now
connects rooks if rook captures then the
rook can capture rook F to c8 we have
Bishop to d3 g6
night the g3 Bishop to f8 rook to a2 and
C for now Bishop to B 1 and here we have
Queen to d8 and here comes a move that
is totally a carpet move you know how I
often say here comes a towel move well
here comes a carp remove the carpet move
is Bishop to a7 and with this Bishop to
a7 move carpel now completely controls
da file there is nothing black can do to
prevent this
now Karpov is free to play Bishop to c2
for example place the other look on a1
so double up rooks on the a file he has
a closed center and now he closed the
any counter play from black on the Queen
side and then he will transfer the game
to the King side so we have 98 Bishop -
C - now now Karpov continues with his
plan tonight the c7 and we have rook eat
a one Queen to e7
as you can see black doesn't really have
all that many moves you can play the
rooks are pretty much useless they're
nice don't have
anywhere to go you can't break open
wouldn't move like f5 since that five is
guarded by the pawn by the bishop and by
the knight and g3 so not a lot of
options for black here black simply has
to wait and see what carpel will do
bishop to be won by Karpov Bishop 3:8
Knight to e2 Knight to d8 and night to H
do now Karpov prepared the position to
push f4 and finally break open on the
Kings side so Bishop to g7 and here f4
by Karpov so still but really can't
react to this if he captures for example
he captures on f4 then Knight captures
on f4 and there really isn't anything
for black to play here unfortunately a
move like Bishop to h6 trying to relieve
some pressure doesn't work because of
Knight captures on g6 and now if you
capture the Queen you simply lose here
with check this comes with another with
a fork so black will now lose the
exchange as well
so after this Knight captures on f4 and
Bishop to h6 you couldn't capture the
Queen you probably have to play
something like F captures or H captures
and after Queen captures on h6 this
completely winning position for white so
after this f4 move by Karpov f6 was
played here Karpov pushes f5 and once
ago was probably very happy when he saw
a 5f5 that he can lock the position with
the g5 but it's a hardly a lock position
here a carp of Na has a has a genius
plan now
Karpov controls the a file he completely
locked down the position and now he will
remove the pretty much the only active
piece black casts and that piece is the
bishop on e8 now he will Riemann over
his own light square Bishop all the way
to h5 and exchange it for onizuka's
light square bishop so Bishop to c2 by
Karpov Bishop to f7 night
the g3 nice to b7 Bishop to d1
h6 now like really can only wait
Bishop to h5 and Queen to e8 now Queen
to d1 protecting the bishop and h5
Knights to d8
rook to a3 King to f8 and the rook 1 to
a 2 we have King to g8 and now Knight to
g4 a small tactic even if it's a
completely closed position Karpov still
manages to had to find the tactic that
it allows him to improve the position of
his Knight that was on h2 now if you
capture the bishop with the bishop
captures you simply lose a piece because
after Knight captures you can't
recapture with the Queen because the
Knight captures on f6 with check after
Bishop character simply Queen captures
on h5 you lose the Queen
so after Knight to g4 King back to f8
now the bishop can be captured because
there is no more check
but now Knight c3 improving the position
of this night we have King to g8 and now
finally Bishop captures on f7 Knight
captors on f7 and Queen to h5 and
although it's a it's a it's a better
position for white I'm sure everyone can
see that but it's still interesting how
Karpov manages to convert Knight back to
d8 offering a trade of Queens but now
another Karpov Ian move Queen to g6 and
this is this is a wild move now Karpov
has a free h5 Square for the night this
night can also come to g4 and pressure
f6 and h6 and here the black who really
doesn't have a move if you capture with
Queen captures then after F captures on
g6 and now Karpov controls even more
squares and it will simply be a slow
painful death for both men goons occur
for example 98 to protect some pawns
here and you do have to make a move
Knight to f5
Bishop to f8 now protecting this bone
and this point is well controlling the
knight on f5 but then rook to a5 going
after the b5 pawn and after we defend
this with Knight to c7 now the simple
Bishop to b6 threatening to remove the
defender of to b5 pawn for example
captures captures and there is
no way to defend the b5 phone but there
are even greater threats after rook to
a7 so 98 but now rook to a7 and black
really doesn't have anything to play
here
so after this Queen to g6 move Hunziker
doesn't capture the Queen he tries came
to f8 and in this position Karpov simply
plays Knight to h5 and in this position
German Grandmaster
Wolfgang Gonzaga resigned the game so if
you look at this position it's it's
beautiful you know so many pieces on the
board I think they just exchanged the
light square Bishop s' and that's it and
that's the only piece that Karpov
actually wanted to exchange since it was
the only piece that was actually doing
something in blacks camp it wasn't doing
much it was you know it was just there
guarding this diagonal so in this
position one seeker resigned there's
really nothing to play here if you
capture the Queen then pretty much the
same idea as before if you play
something like Queen to d7
then again Bishop to b6 for example
captures captures again what has to play
something for example Knight b7 now
Knight captures Queen captures Queen
captures King captures and now comes
this rook to a7 you will win back win
back the piece not win back the piece
you will win win a piece here either
this night will be captured or if this
Knight moves then this night will be
captured with check so it's a completely
winning position for Karpov black is
completely without a move after this
night to h5 so it's not really too
strong but I mean it is a 2-1 whatever
black place loses the game but he can
move a couple of pieces for example now
that yeah he really can play Queen e7 or
Queen to f7 but other than that it's
it's pretty much perfect to lose one
some people even consider this to be a
carp of the mortal game some people
consider his game against Apollo to be
his immortal game but I don't think
there's like an official committee that
did clay that declares of which game is
player's immortal game
so that's the game basically I do hope
you enjoyed it as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here thank you
all for watching and I will see you soon